[Music]
oh it smells so good in here our own
cooking confidence coach nanny bubby is
back in studio and today we're learning
how to make
mac and cheese do you know why because
everybody knows when you hear july 14th
you think yeah that's mac and cheese day
everybody knows that right not funny who
knew that yeah come on it's on my
calendar
oh go ahead i was gonna say
this is sponsored by chapman automotive
and wisconsin that is correct and i
really wanted to know how to celebrate
national macaroni and cheese day so i
reached out to the wisconsin cheese
association who represent the great
dairy farmers of wisconsin and i was
really amazed to find out that they have
over 600 artisanal cheeses in 600 yes
not factory cheese but artisanal cheese
wow and so when i tell you to go to
wisconsincheese.com
look for this logo because if you don't
see this logo you're not the right site
i made that mistake so i want to be sure
you know what it looks like and what you
find i mean it is amazing to find but
there is a video of the wisconsin dairy
farmers on that website and you can see
the pride and the love honestly the love
that they have for their land for their
animals and for the artisanal way in
which they make the cheese so it's
really quite amazing i came up with a
name for wisconsin i call it the dairy
state the dairy system just came up for
the cheesehead state effort
they are the dairy state and on top of
that you should have a lot of pride in
them because they have won more awards
for cheese than any state in the union
and any country in the world so what
country in the country so shall we make
some macaroni
mac and cheese okay so we're gonna both
start with a roux we both have the same
thing you can stir that
and what we have in this is butter flour
two and a half cups of milk each has
some land o'lakes sharp white cheddar
cheese and some copper uh kettle
parmesan and also some mascarpone got it
okay okay
now we're both going to add nutmeg okay
start stirring okay start stirring i'll
stir in a minute a lot of black pepper
in yours because this is the adult mac
and cheese and i do like a lot of yup
that we're turning into jalapeno mac and
cheese and just a little pepper in this
so let's stir it up okay
that's it now from here that same exact
recipe for the kids i'm going to put in
some grand cru which is
switzerland inspired so like swiss
cheese and you are going to put in i
asked for pepper jack but amazing to
think they sent me listen to this let
your mouth water
mango habanero cheese
whoa okay so put that whole thing in go
for it okay and then now you put in
these chopped jalapenos from nanny
bubby's garden
right from my garden by the way aren't
you impressed i am impressed
so now
clean hands chef's best tools about a
cup of yellow cheddar
um from henning's yellow cheddar okay
naming all these cheeses they're so
amazing to think and now we're mixing
them up it will start to melt and as it
does we're going to now you can help me
then i'll help you okay pour in
the uh
i don't know i guess i don't need it yet
it's when i pour it in the
pan and we're going to start mixing it
now for the kids i put in bow ties and
elbow macaroni
and for the adults here i'll grab it for
you okay we'll just put in regular
macaroni you got it okay so you stir
that up
and then
all right so then we're going to put it
into the into the plate the pot and
we'll use that for yours and this one
for mine and then on top of this we are
going to put a panko butter crust now
let me tell you this panko butter crust
you can see it look at this yeah i've
already melted the butter in it and i
put in smoked paprika and that is what
gives it its golden color oh yeah as
well as some cheddar cheese now you know
for kids
when they see the smoked paprika they
may say like on deviled eggs oh no i
don't want that but you say oh yeah i
put it in your mac and cheese all the
time and they go you do and then you
have a way of introducing something new
to them that they love it that they
didn't see so you're saying lie to the
kids got it
okay worked for me for 30 years okay so
all right ready yes okay so we got 30
seconds so let's do 30 seconds yeah
i didn't realize how far out the tv
version yeah okay yep here we go the
magic of tv we will now pull from the
oven the finished oh and it does look
hot
look at that can you taste that yes that
looks beautiful there you go nice
jalapeno mac and cheese kids mac and
cheese start to finish how long can
someone expect uh about 35 minutes
that's great yeah there you go oh i
can't wait to dig into this this is
going to be great i know it's so great
seeing you great seeing you too all
right check out nanny bobby's kitchen
and garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com also want to thank
chapman automotive and the good folks at
wisconsin cheese for sponsoring the
segment we have more las vegas now after
we talked to rocky
after you give me a bite of that mac and
cheese kendall thank you